hey everyone so after hitting a low of
14.38 on february 24 polka dot is once
again on the rise polka dot has
recovered significantly from its lows
and is currently trading at
22.34 dollars
according to
coinmarketcap.com the 11th largest
cryptocurrency and blockchain platform
has a 22 billion dollar market
with these figures it is easy to
envision that polka dot are becoming
more and more popular
so there is no imminent threat to
bitcoin's reign as it continues to rank
first among cryptocurrencies however
polka dot is becoming more popular and
possess a threat to other well-known
cryptocurrencies like ethereum
so considering this huge phrase of polka
dot i have brought you a fully fledged
video on polkadot so keep watching to
explore all the interesting concepts
regarding
so let's have a look at today's agenda
first i will take you through what is
polka dot followed by who is building it
then i will make you understand the
working of polka dot
and after that i will take you through
connecting dots
and what one can do with these dots
then i will help you figure out why you
should consider polka dot and at last
how staking works on polkadot
so let's start the video but before
moving ahead please do subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
so let's move on and let me give you a
crisp introduction to what is polka dot
well polka dot is the first fully
sharded blockchain which means it will
enable a completely decentralized web
where users are in control
basically it's designed to link public
and permission networks or vehicles
private and consortium chains and yet to
be developed future technologies through
the polkadot relay chain polka dot
enables an internet where separate
blockchains can communicate data and
transactions in an untrusted manner
decentralized institutions services and
apps are now easier to build and link
than ever before
polkadot aims to liberate society from
its reliance on a broken web where it's
powerfully institutions cannot betray
our confidence by giving entrepreneurs
the tools they need to create better
solutions
now this whole explanation raises a
question of who is responsible for
building polka dot
so let me explain you the web 3
foundation a swiss organization
established to promote a fully
functional and user-friendly
decentralized web has made polka dot its
flagship project
now to build polka dot and encourage the
creation of the services and apps that
will run on it the bread3 foundation is
collaborating with top tier
organizations
a world-class implementation of web 3
with polka dot at its core is being
developed by researchers from indriya
paris and eth zurich
developers from parity technologies and
capital partners from cryptocurrency
funds like polychain capital
in fact do you know that brands are
being offered by the web3 foundation for
ecosystem growth
well so moving on let me take you
through the working of polka dot
because so many para genes help the main
relay chain with a lot of the heavy
lifting polka dot is able to analyze all
this data as a result compared to around
seven for bitcoin and 30 for ethereum
the bold network can execute more than
1000 transactions per second now polka
dot should become much faster if the
network expands and more power chains
are added and then the speed can reach a
million transactions per second as well
now
let me take you through a very important
aspect of polka dot network which is
very evident in its name itself and that
is dot
now the native token of the poll cutout
network is
dot
transaction fees taking governance
purchasing a power chain space and
enabling a number of crucial polka dot
features
may all be done with dot now these dots
can be connected in multiple ways so
let's discuss them one by one first is
relay chain it's polka dots core aspect
and is in charge of the network's
interpolability across chains consensus
and shared security
second is
parachains
now these are independent blockchains
that are capable of creating their own
coins and tailoring their functionality
to particular use cases
third is para thread which is similar to
parrot chains but uses a pay as your go
payment system
now blockchains without a constant
connection to the network are most more
cost effective
fourth is bridges now this enables
connections and communication between
parachains and para threats and other
networks like ethereum and bitcoin
so now that i have already discussed
about dots let me give you a quick
overview of how one can use these dots
so
if you have one dot it is bare minimum
balance needed to maintain an active
polka dot network account
now your account will be deleted if the
amount falls below one dot
so find out more about accounts and the
need for existing deposits
then we have
five dot
to participate in crowd loans for parrot
chain slot auctions you must make a
minimum contribution of this amount
then we have 10 dot
it is the bare minimum stake necessary
to submit your nomination of validator's
purpose however in order to receive
staking incentives your stake must be
greater than the dynamic minimum stay
among active nominators
find out how to nominate people
and then it's 20 dot
you can cast a council vote or register
an on-chain identity now the democracy
of polkadot benefit from dot to make
suggestions to support them and to vote
on them when they become
referendums
dot must be bonded
to submit a treasury proposal 100 dot in
bonds of five percent of the required
funds must be provided
now you may be able to take part in
initiatives like the thousand validators
programs thanks to dot
now moving ahead let me tell you about
why you should consider polka dot
so polka dot provides a platform for
everyone regardless of whether you are a
blockchain developer or just interested
in being a part of the community this
wiki provider a location for builders
and maintainers to use tools and for new
students to explore educational content
now let me tell you about how speaking
actually works on polka dot
so in order to protect the network
or validate transactions or generate and
distribute new dot polka dot uses a
proof of stake consensus process
depending on how much time technical
expertise and money they wish to invest
dot holders can engage
with this taking mechanism in a variety
of ways like validators
who do the most work it's a big
commitment and calls for technological
expertise you must maintain a node or
one of the computers that makes up the
network with little to no downtime and
take a sizeable portion of your own dot
in order to become a validator
now you gain the ability to approve
valid transactions and add new blocks of
the transaction to the relay chain and
potentially establish dot while also
receiving a cut of transaction fees and
tips in return
next we have is nominators
they enable everyday investors to take
part in staking covertly you can trust a
validator to follow the rules if you
give them part of your dot in return you
receive a portion of the dot that your
selected validators earn
now you risk losing some of your stake
if your validators violates the rules so
choose carefully any of the jobs
mentioned above will allow you to stake
and participate in the network in order
to be eligible for dot awards
holders of dots can vote on propose
software changes and have a see in how
the network is run
so this was all about polka dots and its
related concepts i hope you enjoyed this
video and learned something new from it
if you have any questions please feel
free to ask away in the comment section
our team will definitely reach you back
as soon as possible
stay safe thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here